players still wonder to this day if
breath of the wild's discoveries will
ever end and that answer is
no
one of the most recent discoveries
breaks the game in multiple ways never
seen before and that is inventory slot
transfer and in this video i'll teach
you why this works and explain the basic
concept of it if you'd like to keep up
to date with everything breath of the
wild make sure to stay tuned with us
here on gamespot
first found by zx robin inventory slot
transfer can manipulate the menu and
inventory items in ways that wasn't
possible before this led to multiple
incredible discoveries starting from
basic item duplication to duplicating
stamina meals hundreds of times for
endless stamina creating tens of
thousands of fairies to become
invincible and never care about being
hit again rediscover secrets that
nintendo previously patched such as the
hidden ice cream even glitch the save
prompts using save prompt storage into
cut scenes to save and load into that
cutscene and explore a peaceful
liberated hyrule with calamity's pillars
blue and a malice free world the last
canon state of hyrule before going into
breath of the wild 2. but that's not
even the best part we finally accessed
the world of customizing weapon
modifiers and putting them on weapons
normally impossible these official
nintendo modifiers that were never
released are now possible such as 10
shot wide bows 10 shot linear bows and
even the hidden surf up modifier it's
hard to believe that one glitch led to
this many discoveries already however
before we go any further i've got to
give you three warnings this video is
going to explain the base idea of ist
the other glitches like safe prompt
storage and weapon modifier corruption
are massive ideas on their own and
require an entire separate video to
explain but you will need to understand
what i'm explaining here first secondly
if this is something you're trying to do
yourself i would not recommend doing
this on your main file if done
improperly without planning beforehand
it can lead to multiple unsellable armor
unusable korok seats and or shrine orbs
a bunch of duplicated unusable arrows
you can't refill which all technically
can be fixed but it takes a lot of extra
work therefore i recommend never manual
saving until absolutely necessary double
checking your glitched outcomes through
auto saves instead or i personally still
recommend starting a fresh file or
profile as a side project third this is
much more complex than how i'm going to
explain it ist includes working with
game data save data m count offsets
desync corruption and more but for
simplicity's sake i'm going to try to
reduce the fancy words as much as
possible to focus on the visual basic
concept without further ado let's
explain the basics of breaking your file
for the easy version you need five to
six multi-shot bows at least one shock
arrow materials with at least two of
each and a shopkeeper this can be done
with beetles as stables if you'd like
but personally i like doing this in busy
towns hoteno village is a popular pick
due to being close to home to rack up
your equipment cooking pots nearby and a
good shopkeeper next thing you'll want
to do is think about what you want to
duplicate let's say for now we want to
duplicate fairies and diamonds this
process is always going to vary in
difficulty depending on what you want
but the general rule is whatever the
thing it is you want have it as close to
the right of the menu as possible you
can achieve this by selling off dropping
and picking up or eating as much as you
can before these items
now that you've got your gear and your
targets to duplicate you can start the
offsetting process let's start by
performing a basic menu overload stand
near your vendor then pull out any
multi-shot bow with the shock arrow
equipped go into the menu and then drop
the bow
then go over to the next bow and equip
the next one exit the menu then pause
again repeat this until link starts
losing some limbs and body parts
if you're still having trouble getting
him to overload fully try equipping one
elemental rod on his back to push it
just a tad more
in the meantime keep that bow equipped
and held in his hands for now now go to
the materials tab and hold four
different items in your hands
exit the menu and if link puts his arms
down you smuggled successfully if he
held these items in his hands try this
process again you don't want to see the
items in your hands now hold zr then
d-pad right and unequip the bow if done
correctly you'll now be smuggling four
items and not be overloaded anymore head
over to the shopkeeper and go ahead and
sell the entire stack of four items in
your hands
[Music]
stop talking to the shopkeeper go into
your menu and just press a on any fifth
material in your menu then exit out and
press a again to drop it
this is where the magic happens what
just happened was link tossed on the
ground one real material and four
invisible materials that never existed
because they were sold out of your hands
before you threw them this tells the
game that you deleted 4 slots but
without dropping any materials which is
called offset slots here we made four
now reload your file
the fairies and diamonds are now
duplicated
this is where i'll have to explain
what's going on behind the scenes a
little further okay let's step back and
do a simpler example of this with all
the equipment in a straight line let's
say link this time now holds a
traveler's sword a bow normal arrows
traveler's shield
five materials hearty simmered fruit
meal and his handy shiga slate and
paraglider 12 items total in normal
gameplay when you sell the four items
entirely it reduces your four slots
along with it so now you have 8 items
and everything is fine every time you
reload the game what actually happens is
the game confirms that you do indeed
have 8 items on you then delete every
single item you own starting from the
left side the weapons tab this is
because it's designed around a system
called an intrusive linked list without
pretending to know too much about this
this is a data system that remembers
things in chain order rather than
erasing and copying data individually
when you load back in the game says you
have eight items to load back in this is
called m count the game copies those
eight items into those eight slots in
that order with this system and
everything is good and dandy
now let's see what we did to mess with
this system this time same inventory but
we perform the glitch sell our items
which reduces our m count by four but
then as we exit the shopkeeper we throw
those four items on the ground which
reduces your m count by an additional
four slots but without dropping any
materials now the game thinks you have
four items in your inventory but you
actually have eight
now when reloading your save this time
you're telling the game i have four m
count the game like usual starts to
delete one by one starting from the left
once it gets to fairies though something
happens it stops counting these last
four slots are then simply carried over
when reloading because they technically
never left
that's why the originals show up at the
beginning of the materials tab because
when you reloaded it deleted those
materials starting from the left side
then got those materials and then sorted
those materials into the tabs of the
file you just loaded
so why aren't some things duplicated
like the sheikah slate and the
paraglider well there's a special check
in the game for several items saying
that you can only have one of them ever
which goes for most key items so it
won't duplicate which is great news for
us actually
there's a bunch of special exceptions
for this but the main rule is arrows and
duplicatable key items are the enemy
they fill up your inventory with
unusable stuff so try to have a file
with minimal to no arrows and less
duplicatable key items to have a better
time as complicated as just this is this
is just the base technique of inventory
slot transfer and this basic concept can
be used in complex ways to go even
farther you can reload again and again
to duplicate multiple items multiple
times bring the bow of light into any
file you want transfer basically
whatever item you want from any file
onto any save even between normal and
master mode files even start a new game
with the glitched food menu to further
glitch the save prompt into a cut scene
and load into unattended areas like the
end of the game and explore hyrule with
calamine again and defeat it and
everyone's favorite discovery so far to
unlock powerful forgotten modifiers
nintendo never released
by creating offset slots to match your
key items and 60 recipes the 60th
recipe's values corrupts the closest
equipment's modifiers and creates some
of the most powerful equipment ever seen
in the game all possible on any nintendo
switch around the world it's a broken
record now but breath of the wild's
discoveries just don't stop it's
guaranteed something will be found year
over year and the whole community puts
in a ton of work to make this research
happen
thanks for watching and if you want a
tutorial for weapon modifier corruption
let us know in the comments below for
everything else gaming keep it here on
gamespot
[Music]
[Music]